Motor vehicle directional signals have been
around almost as long as cars, and as early
as 1909, a device was patented that had hand-shaped
lights that indicated to other drivers which
way a vehicle intended to travel.
Obviously, that one didn’t catch on.
Neither did the mechanical signaling device
invented by silent-film star Florence Lawrence
in 1914, which, after a button was pushed
by the driver, a sign would pop up from the
rear bumper indicating which way the car was
turning.
The first modern directional signal was patented
in 1925 by Edgar A. Walz, Jr., although no
one was interested in it either, at least
until after his patent expired 14 years later.
That’s when, in 1939, the U.S. automaker
Buick first introduced the “Flash–Way
Directional Signal,” which operated in the
familiar way – a stick, mounted on the steering
column.
In its original incarnation, this turn signal
only flashed the rear lights; by the next
year, front lights were flashing as well.
By the end of WWII, directional signals were
standard in most American automobiles.
While there are several different designs
out there for turn signal switches, they classically
used some form of a thermal switch (in this
case called a thermal flasher).
The core of this switch includes a resistor
that heats up when current flows through it.
This is attached to a bimetallic spring- essentially
an arched strip made up of two sandwiched
metals with very different thermal properties,
one that expands quite a bit as it warms and
the other that doesn’t.
The result is that when current is flowing
(when you turn on the blinker), the resistor
heats up the arched bimetallic spring which
in turn is connecting the two terminals, allowing
the lights to come on.
As it heats up, one of the metals begins to
try to straighten itself out as it expands,
but initially can’t because the other metal
is holding it in its arched form.
Eventually, the heat builds enough where the
metal trying to straighten itself out wins
the battle and the bimetallic spring straightens,
disconnecting the two terminals.
At this point, no electricity is flowing and
the lights are off.
Because no power is flowing, the resistor
and the bimetallic spring rapidly cool to
the point where the other metal pressing to
reform itself into the arched shape wins,
and there is another snap as it once again
bends back into shape and re-connects the
terminals, starting the process over again.
So in these thermal flashers, the clicking
noise you hear is just this bimetallic spring
snapping back and forth from its arched form
to a straightened form and back again.
One tell-tale sign that you have a thermal
flasher in your car is that when a light goes
out, the flash rate of your blinkers will
slow down- less electricity = more time needed
for sufficient heat to build to snap the spring.
In the extreme, where too little current is
flowing (like if you try to swap out your
incandescent bulbs for LEDs), your blinker
will simply not blink, staying on.
On the other end of the spectrum, if you hook
up a trailer or something with more lights,
it will speed up the blinking rate and in
the extreme perhaps even damage your thermal
flasher.
Another common device used to create the blink
in your blinkers is an electronic flasher.
Instead of using heat and a bimetallic spring,
this device simply uses some electronic circuit
to control a relay.
Inside a mechanical relay, applied electricity
to an electromagnet creates a magnetic field
that switches a metallic armature, which in
turn makes an audible clicking noise.
When the electricity is no longer applied
to the electromagnet in the relay, a spring
moves the armature back the other way, either
connecting the circuit or disconnecting depending
on the type of relay (whether it’s designed
to be switched on or off by default).
This type of system has the advantage of not
inherently changing the blink rate based on
the electrical draw of the lights.
So switching to LED lights or hooking up trailer
lights won’t necessarily affect anything,
though this does vary somewhat depending on
the design of the circuit, particularly in
how the system is designed to detect and respond
to a burnt out light bulb.
But, in general, as long as you’re not drawing
more power than the wires, fuse, etc. can
handle, the system should blink at a constant
rate, with the relay clicking away as it switches
the lights on and off.
There is also another type of electronic flasher
that is a solid state flasher, meaning it
has no moving parts (making it incredibly
long lasting and reliable), perhaps using
a solid state relay.
This type of system does not inherently click
unless the designer specifically chose to
add something to do so, possibly added as
an extra indicator to the driver that the
blinker is on.
In most cases, though, there will be no click
with a solid state flasher.